vu le ballon d'or hier ouais ouais
ballon d'or et ouais c'est messi ballon
d'or bon j'aime beaucoup mais si mais
j'aurais aimé que j'aurais préféré que
ce soit karim bâ qui gagnent ou qu'ils
gagnent karim benzema qui mérite et on
va pas se mentir je suis désolé des mecs
un lâcher un petit coup de gueule voilà
karine savez je laime c'est des
journalistes en et joris du moins d'en
tirer pour tuer l'un des mods
journalistes du monde en faisant 80
c'est là exactement et c'est vrai que
franchement c'est honteux de ne pas
l'avoir donné avec karim benzema je suis
désolé mais si on aime beaucoup mais il
n'a pas fait une saison de fou là il
méritait pas son septième ballon d'or
pour moi c'était karim qui devait
vraiment l'avoir c'était je sais oui je
vous dise je je je je crie au complot
tony karim je suis très énervé que karim
benzema n'est pas eu le ballon d'or
parce qu'ils le méritent et il a fait
c'est incroyable il à laon et encore la
semaine dernière il fait un match de fou
il est incroyable voilà mais c'est vrai
que je suis pas pourquoi ne donne pas
pris non pas dominant il ya un sentiment
d'injustice parce qu'il est décisif
orale de madrid il a fait un bon retour
en équipe de france 2 que messi il a
gagné la copa america c'est tout l'art
et gagner d'autres le barça a été
chassée pas gagné non plus il avait déjà
eu mais si mais si c'est un joueur
fantastique c'est d'être un des
meilleurs joueurs de tous les temps mais
c'était c'était le tour de benzema ça
avant de le disais c'est ça c'est
incompréhensible a mérité pas voilà
c'était banzaï ou lewandowski voilà
alors simplement v1d2 voila mail à la
messi s'est succédée 4e revient pas
second trois exactement sur le 4e quart
omnium voilà c'est en tout cas pour
karim je te le dis un frère ou tout à
l'heure pour moi c'est toi le ballon
d'or cette année et tu le sais voilà et
pour beaucoup de monde c'est toi le vrai
ballon d'or cette année même si je pense
qu'il n'a rien contre eux mais signe
alors il ya une petite barque a en tout
cas dans cette cérémonie qui est
extrêmement suivi 1,6 million
téléspectateurs pour suivre le ballon
d'or c'est un record pour célébrer la
victoire de lionel messi la tour eiffel
s'est illuminé et genre il avait annoncé
à lionel messi un truc de ouf sauf que
frère c'était mais
je te demande et
de presser ce buzzer chez toi ici à
paris avec ce 7e ballon d'or france
football et c'est super
c'est pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
mais c'est pas non plus à ce que la tour
eiffel toutes les heures et de sa vie
comme en non mais c'est vrai nous
n'aurons donc pas de bêtises dans la
bouenza les couleurs de
l'alléger son nom et faire sinon oui et
faire mais mu mais si le pauvre il a
regardé s'est laissé éclater au sous-sol
ce que tu me fais là mais alors je les
aime beaucoup et frère c'est que c'est
quoi là c'est quoi sa librairie a duré
la surprise d'anna les connaît mais
s'est éclaté au sous sol voilà je pense
pas mériter que les effets spéciaux
n'étaient pas exactement où ils adorent
mais si moi j'ai rien contre lui c'est
toujours ça c'est le meilleur joueur du
monde des années d'une allée cristiano
giallorossi mais cette année c'était le
tour de karim voilà je sais pas pourquoi
car il n'y a pas eu mais je veux dire
emmenez-le enquête il faut dire que ça
va chier les vainqueurs